so good afternoon
gasprom's announcement that it is
unilaterally stopping gas deliveries to
certain eu member states is another
provocation from the kremlin
but it comes as no surprise
that the kremlin uses fossil fuels to
try to blackmail us
this is something the european
commission has been preparing for
in close coordination and solidarity
with member states and international
partners
our response will be immediate
united and coordinated
first we will ensure that gazprom's
decision
has the least possible impact on
european consumers
today member states met in the gas
coordination group
poland and bulgaria updated us on the
situation
both poland and bulgaria are now
receiving gas from their eu neighbors
and this shows first of all the immense
solidarity among us but it also shows
the effectiveness of past investments
for example in interconnectors and other
gas infrastructure
the commission will intensify its work
with the so-called regional groups of
member states
these regional groups of member states
can provide the most immediate
solidarity to each other if needed
and this will mitigate any impacts on
possible gas disruptions
second
we will continue our work to ensure
sufficient gas supply and storage in the
medium term
our action plan we power eu will help to
significantly reduce our dependency on
russian fossil fuels
already this year
we have as you know
also reached an agreement with the
united states to provide additional lng
imports this year and the following ones
and we are working hand-in-hand with our
member states to secure alternative gas
supplies from other partners too
in the longer term
repower eu will also help us move to a
more reliable secure and sustainable
energy supply
we will present our plans to speed up
the green transition in mid-may
and to make it very clear every euro
that we invest in renewables and in
energy efficiency is a down payment on
our future energy independence
the latest aggressive move from russia
is another very stark reminder that we
need to work with reliable partners and
build our energy independence
the commission is in contact with the
french presidency and i welcome their
plans to convene a meeting of eu energy
ministers as soon as possible
today the kremlin failed once again
in his attempt to sow division among
member states
the era of russian fossil fuel in europe
is coming to an end
europe is moving forward on energy
issues thank you very much
thank you eric madam president martinez
from the new york times
do you have any insights can you confirm
or do you have any details as to a story
in bloomberg news earlier today that
says that 10 european energy companies
are preparing to make rubles payments
for gazprom gas and four companies have
already made such payments can you tell
us if such a move
shouldn't be happening by european
union-based companies would in fact
constitute a violation of eu sanctions
thank you very much for the question
this allows me to clarify once again
our guidance here is very clear
to pay in rubles
if this is not foreseen in the contract
to pay in rubles is a breach of our
sanctions we have around about 97 of all
contracts that explicitly stipulate
payments in euros or dollars so it's
very clear and the request from the
russian side to pay in rubles is a
unilateral decision and not
according to the contracts
companies with such contracts should not
accept to the russian demands
this would be a breach of the sanctions
so a high risk for the companies
thank you last question
thank you it's the rotter from polish tv
polls that
president you said about the reaction
that commission is preparing in the
european union
regarding the
supplying poland with gas from other
member states improving the storage of
gas but is there or will there be any
reaction uh regarding the relations of
the european union with russia after uh
what what moscow has done stopping the
the gas flows the polish ambassador
apparently uh told you today that in
reply to what happened the sixth
sanction package should have been
implemented immediately including
embargo on russia oil and gas
the sixth package of sanctions will come
in due time
we are working intensively on it
the move that russia did today
is basically a move where russia hurts
itself
the kremlin is hurting the russian
economy because
they are cutting off themselves from
important revenues
nonetheless we are working hard not only
to get rid of the coal as we've done
already but also we are working on the
topic of oil
and we you have seen today that the
question of gas dependency on russia
we've been working since month to reduce
this dependency it pays off now
um we have reduced already the flow of
gas coming from russia
and with the plans i've just displayed
we will be able to get independent of
russian fossil fuels much faster and
this is for good and forever
thank you